all right this week's classic interview
very relevant to what's been going on in
the media and in society over the last
six months my interview with Joshua
Turner from back in June of 2015 Joshua
Turner was a former Christian or is a
former Christian neo-nazi and he is an
incredible story of how critical
thinking and reasonable analysis of our
world took him out of very extremist
circles I don't think it needs much more
introduction than that my interview with
Joshua Turner from June of 2015 I'm
joined today by Joshua Turner who's
president and founder of America's first
secular prison outreach organization
called saved by reason and when I heard
about Joshua's story I wanted to get him
on the show to talk about it because it
is really an incredible story and it
involves everything from drug addiction
crime at a young age a prison sentence
and ultimately neo-nazi anti-science
ideology and so much more let's what's
the best place to start Joshua I think
it would be tell us a little bit sort of
about the context of your childhood yeah
absolutely I think that's where it all
starts as it does for everybody we pick
up you know a lot of the personalities
and traits as we're you know growing up
as children and we pick a lot of that up
from our parents and my parents happen
to be evangelical Christian they were
extremely fundamentalist my mother had a
very hard upbringing and you know she
experienced some really really rough
things that I couldn't even imagine
going through myself so when she was 17
years old she became a Christian and she
was just like full you know full bore so
she ended up becoming a Pentecostal and
joined Calvary Chapel which was a
fundamentalist Christian group that I
grew up in and when I say irrational i I
do really mean irrational if anybody's
read my blog I tell a story about my mom
and dad sitting my brother and I down
I was eight years old my brother was six
they sat us down and and told us that we
were gonna be facing what is called the
mark of the beast and basically nobody
could buy sell or trade any kind of food
without taking the mark of the beast and
you know credit cards are just a sign
that word that's a much closer to that
type of technology of having a mark or a
chip in your arm where you can just scan
it and so my parents literally believed
because it says in Revelation that to
buy sell or trade food during the end
times that you would need to take this
mark and they they believed because
their pastor told them that this that
this was happening very very soon like
within the next few years they told me
and my brother that we would be held
down and tortured in front of my parents
so that they would take the mark but
under any circumstances we couldn't take
it and did you believe this stuff
literally as they were telling it to you
yeah absolutely I mean you you're gonna
believe what your parents tell you 8
years old especially when they're
calling up a very serious family meeting
and they're full of tears and they're
crying and you know you guys are praying
all night that you know that God will
just allow a quick death and just a
beheading instead of all the torture and
yeah I absolutely believed it and I mean
how did that so that was from a very
young age and and now you talk about the
the religious fundamentalism of that was
there also any of the neo-nazi ideology
that you eventually fell into that came
from your parents or was that totally
separate I would say that it was the
hate was separate my parents never
justified or supported racism they
believed that we're all God's people but
they were extremely right-wing my father
listened to Rush Limbaugh their anti
liberal they they have lots of
intolerance towards the gay community
towards minority communities because of
crime so they don't they didn't hate
based on race but they did have
intolerance and right-wing ideology so
that
definitely kind of pushed me in the
direction towards neo-nazism or at least
made that step a lot easier for me
because I had already grown up around
you know right-wing voices and when you
were 14 what happened that pushed you
towards the drugs and the crime really
that was just my way I think of lashing
out and rebelling really yeah you know
when you when you're doing things at
that age you don't really know why
you're doing them at the time and so
when he grow up you you reflect and you
try to realize what was going on in your
head at the time but yeah I think I was
just lashing out and rebelling because
things were so strict at home I I was an
artist I loved to draw as a kid and that
was suppressed at home my parents didn't
want me they didn't like what I drew you
know I've drawn into Turtles and stuff
and they wanted me to draw Jesus and
Moses and so I was just really sheltered
and I didn't I wasn't allowed to grow
into the person that I wanted to be so I
think that drugs and I'm just you know
hanging out with the wrong crowd was my
way of just lashing out I'm trying to
find out who I was and as this continued
you were eventually convicted of
carjacking and you end up in the
California prison system and what's that
like
well in prison if you're white basically
your only choices are to run with the
woods or the skinheads the woods there's
a huge range of what the woods are
categorized as but basically not if they
range anywhere from non-affiliated gang
members that just stick to their county
they you know hang out with whatever
county they're from and then it can go
all the way up to Aryan brothers several
white supremacist gang z' that aren't
necessarily neo-nazi in their ideology
but just racist or you know like the
Klan and stuff they're considered woods
and then there's the skinheads and
they're a lot more structured they're
united by neo Nazi ideology they didn't
use drugs at least they weren't supposed
to
so yeah I hung out I didn't hang out
with actual skinheads in my town because
there really wasn't any active skinheads
in my town but I guess you could say me
and my friends were posers we'd watched
you know American History X and we were
our Doc Martin boots and got online and
learned what the 14 words were but we
weren't actual skinheads we were just
kind of posers so when I got into the
environment where there was real
skinheads that were indoctrinated with
neo-nazi ideology I had an opportunity
to learn from them so that's what I did
I just felt more comfortable with those
guys a lot of them were Christians
there's a movement called Christian
identity and neo Nazism so yeah I went
with that man it just felt right to me
yeah so what was appealing about it I
mean so you mentioned some familiarity
with a little bit of the ideology the
sort of interplay with the Christian
upbringing that you had was that it or
was there something else that made that
the most appealing path in prison yeah I
mean it really it just it was comforting
because it just felt so familiar you
know I was used to going to church with
all kinds of pageantry and symbology and
songs and that's what the skinheads had
you know what I mean we have our not
some flags up and you know it was just
really similar hanging on the word of
the pastor you know not instead of doing
that out on the street as a Christian
now I was hanging on every word of our
skinhead leader and yeah the psychology
behind it is very similar you know as a
Christian we're told you know that we're
not supposed to hate anybody we're
supposed to love and all that but at the
same time you Christians are still
intolerant it's the same thing with
skinheads you know they'll try to tell
you you know we're not about hey we're
about loving our race but at the same
time they're intolerant of other people
so yeah I mean it was just very similar
in all kinds of ways and while you were
in prison as as part of this skinhead
gang that you were running with did you
have to go through any sort of
initiation that you have to commit
violent acts in order to sort of prove
yourself tell us about that no I you
know when I got there I had my
had shaved and I knew the 14 words I
knew a little bit about you know what a
skinhead was so I just kind of just fell
right in and nobody really questioned
whether I had been initiated or not on
the street but no I'd never really was
initiated I just started calling myself
a skinhead and it had they checked they
would have found out that you know I was
not really involved with any neo-nazi
movement or anything I was just an
independent skinhead so you eventually
get out of prison and at this point what
happens with regards to the drugs and
the criminality does that continue and
then what happens as far as your this
skinhead identity that you've taken on
yeah so I got out and what my goal to do
was to be the best neo-nazi that you
could be so you know Christianity we
have a Bible or they have a Bible to
follow and the skinheads have the 14
words and the 88 precepts
so I studied the eighty eight precepts
well not doing drugs was was in the
precepts
so yeah attempted to be a good neo-nazi
but as I had said told you before I
started using drug drugs at 14 years old
and even in prison I was using behind
their back without their knowledge so
quitting drugs was extremely hard for me
and so I really started looking for ways
to get might get help from my drug
addiction I started to kind of move away
from the whole Christianity thing I've
always had doubts about Christianity and
kind of lean towards atheism even when I
was you know in prison and and doing the
Christian identity thing I always had
doubts so I ended up picking up The God
Delusion by Richard Dawkins and that's
basically the turning point for me
that's when I learned that I wasn't
applying critical thinking in my life
and yeah so I want to remind everybody
that we've been speaking with Joshua
Turner who is president and founder of
the secular prison outreach organization
saved by reason we'll take a break and
then we'll have our full interview with
Joshua up on our YouTube channel
so Joshua as you started to I'm actually
curious how did you end up did you go
and look for that Richard Dawkins book
that someone suggested to you what were
the circumstances of just picking that
up oh well my search for truth really
has been a long journey I've read a lot
of philosophy I've read a lot of
theology I've just I've always been
trying to find out the the big answers
that everybody asked you know where we
come from why are we here and I yeah I
was reading a lot of philosophy at the
time and just the one area of philosophy
that I had never really got into was
secularism and materialism and yeah I
think it was a friend of mine who
recommended that the God Delusion
so yeah I picked up the God Delusion and
it was just a domino effect from there
man
then I got Sam Harris and RIT
Christopher Hitchens and Peter Bogosian
and you know just started going from
there and I really got swept up by the
new atheist movement and you know the
only difference here is that I'm not a
follower you know I'm not I'm not a
follower hanging on the words of Richard
Dawkins you know he's I see him as just
a regular person he's just he's just
written a lot of things that have helped
me and you know I've applied those those
things to my life but he's not like
Savior to me or you know some somebody
that I put it on a pedestal or anything
like that and as you started getting
into these readings and moving in a
different direction with regard to your
religion what was going on with the
relationship with your parents who as
you mentioned hardline Christians
Pentecostal etc mm-hmm well didn't go
well you know I wasn't quiet about what
I was learning I I truly believe that
you know secular values and just having
an open mind and being skeptical is it's
just a great way to
to live your life honestly and I just
wanted to share that with my parents so
I started to talk to them about you know
what I was reading and it just honestly
just didn't turn out well
they're very close-minded and not open
to hearing and yet any anybody is else
aside or or anything like that even
though it's coming from their son who
they can see firsthand changing their
life and and totally turning her life
around for the first time we're you know
able to I'm curious whether they were
able to sort of because as you started
reading this type of material not only
were you changing how you were thinking
about the world but you were also
changing your actions right with regard
to being a neo-nazi and being involved
with crime etc were they able to
recognize that even if it wasn't that
they believed literally what it was that
you were reading about that it was at
least correlating with a positive change
in your life I don't even think they're
willing to admit that I think that they
are equating my success with their
prayers you know I tell them all the
time that my wife and I experience
blessings every day and neither one of
us uh ters a single prayer to any deity
so and their response is always what we
pray for you so yeah no didn't let's
talk a little bit about the prison
outreach part of this because we've
we've talked to so many different people
both academics and people who have been
in prison and there is this very strong
tendency to find religion in prison and
then we see that sort of perpetuated
throughout the lives of individuals once
they come out of prison why does that
seem to happen is it the circumstances
of being in prison and religion sort of
seems to be like the natural thing for
people to go to is there something else
that seems to drive people when they're
in that circumstance to look to religion
um really it's just a comfort blanket
when you're in prison you are utterly
alone you're sitting in a cell by
yourself for twenty three hours a lot of
the time and so it's really lonely
and yeah it's just it's really a
comfortably a lot of people that go to
prison haven't had a lot of higher
education myself included so we don't
have much to go on when we're sitting in
there by ourselves and it's just very
just I can't even think of the word but
yeah it's just it sort of comes
naturally in a sense that this is the
way people go just feels like the
obvious thing exactly yeah so what are
you trying to do with save by reason is
the idea obviously the reintegration of
former inmates to society is a huge
issue that we have so what are you doing
along those lines and is the idea to
sort of introduce critical thinking
skills into that yes yeah absolutely
well what's a by reason is is we're
basically a prison outreach organization
for non-believers currently in prison if
you were a Christian or a Muslim or a
Buddhist there's all kinds of
information or outreach programs
ministers that will come and visit you
but if you identify as non religious or
atheist or whatever kind of epithet you
want to use there's absolutely nothing
no program that I'm aware of
there is a center for inquiry they they
do n pals and they do send secular books
and to prisoners but that's it and so
yeah so that's where say by reason comes
in we're filling that void of reaching
out to prisoners that don't identify as
religious and what we do to teach what
we do to use as sort of a because you
know Christians have a book to go off of
the Bible and Muslims have the Koran and
everybody has their little book to go
off of
and as secularists I'm it's my job to
kind of come up with very simple
concepts that will help the inmates
lower their their recidivism by
increasing moral reasoning and critical
thinking skills and one of the
techniques that we use to do that is by
teaching the Socratic method and talk to
us about that so what what in what way
does teaching the Socratic method in
your mind help to prepare
prisoners for when they're out in the
real world to avoid falling into the
same patterns right well with the
Socratic method does is it teaches you
to pause and to reflect on an ideology
or a belief or just a definition of any
of something or just anything something
somebody tells you what the Socratic
method does is it gives you a toolset
so you analyze that whatever you know
you've been told to see if that is
indeed correct or if you agree with it
and you know we find everybody me you
even we we do this you know people just
hand down facts to us people in
authority usually politicians or a boss
or a parent will just tell us something
and we'll just not question it and
assume it's correct and uh so yeah so
that's what the Socratic method does if
you apply it is it helps you to reflect
and to self-analyze and self self
inquiry into into the truth to see if
you agree with yourself and and
essentially you're just living your life
day to day for yourself and you're
believing and acting in in a way that
you agree with and you're not doing
things just because somebody told you
and if people want to learn more about
save by reason where's the best place
for them to do that they can go on our
website say by reason org or they can
follow us on Twitter say by reason all
right I'll tell everybody once again
we've been speaking with Joshua Turner
he is president and founder of the
secular prison outreach organization
saved by reason thanks so much for
telling us your story right on thanks
David it's great to be here man
appreciate it